have you guys been in a lot of fights um
shot i got shot where did you get shot
in the leg right here
that is really close to your deck it's
really close but yeah and it's femoral
artery
was it a bad recovery no um
i i was a flashy person i was releasing
yeah i was lucky it didn't hit an artery
and i was released from the hospital day
but i could
i couldn't like if i had to take a [ __ ]
or whatever i'd have to it was so
swollen i'd have to hold myself
up for a couple weeks yeah because it
was so it was so tender
but times their ass yeah and then the
bullet just stayed in there because it
was so far in that
they they just because your body will
reject a foreign object if it's in there
so it made its way to the surface and
they took it out a couple like two years
later
two years yeah that bullet me for two
years setting off metal detectors it was
fun
why are you like where you use that to
get girls um
yeah girls like stuff like that yeah
scars and bullets do you like it if a
guy was like i have a bullet in my
fleshy part of my thigh i mean i don't
know
you don't know like scary tattoos or
something yeah kind of bullet
because i'm like what did you do what'd
you do to get this were you like
in a fight i used the back story yeah
like we were just walking to get froyo
got robbed well let me just say this
real quick that's what i love about like
um
you know obviously feminism is a good
thing i'm a feminist everyone should be
a feminist but
when people talk about toxic masculinity
it's hilarious like
it's like she just said i want someone
with scary tattoos someone who might
kill me
you know it's like yeah i think women
haven't been like
passive victims of a patriarchy i think
but we are kind of kidding
but yeah but i don't really want to be
scared by a guy no but you like a big
guy you do like a guy who
you feel like could protect you is like
yeah successful
right you're not you're not dating a
social worker are you soft on the inside
yeah somebody that might murder but like
you know what i mean
like women want to be like women want
successful guys with status who also
look like they can [ __ ] someone up if
they're in need but i don't need that
no i don't need somebody to look like
they can be violent i've never really
had it though it's like i want this
thing i don't even like i have no
tattoos i'm never gonna get one i'm like
i wanna go with a bunch of tattoos just
very weird i don't know yeah well yeah
you want like the opposite
stuff yeah i just think women are in
charge more of like
mate you know women are in every species
you look like the women we compete for
them
women are choosing us yeah like the
patriarch is gonna end it's gonna be
like women's tastes are gonna change
which is probably gonna happen
because you we don't need to be like
[ __ ] masculine anymore here's the
thing though
we've i feel like what we talk about a
lot is guys that kind of like
come off a little gay they're hello yes
they're not
but like it used to be years ago you'd
be like oh my god that guy's just and
now we're like i don't care
yeah like i met a guy we were in austin
i was like yeah it kind of translates
gay but he's straight and i'm
i'm fine with it like actually like 10
years ago you'd be like you only wanted
super masculine men
and it's more way more acceptable for
guys like a millennial guy
right like a millennial 21 year old
talks like this but he's like he's a
straight guy like and he's not even
pretending but this is just how he
speaks yeah like you know you do a
college gig and i'll be like
oh yeah take a picture like i thought
you were like you were great yeah
it was like so funny this is my
girlfriend rachel yeah
i'm on the [ __ ] basketball team
you're [ __ ] comedy [ __ ]
awesome you listen to someone like the
guys like an ncaa tournament like when
they're getting interviewed like
i'm just so [ __ ] excited to be in the
ncaa tournament yeah i mean it was like
straight white men they're not white man
they're just straight sure that they're
straight guys in l.a really yeah
i met this guy and i was like rayna was
like he's he seems kind of gay
not just kind of getting really gay i
was like or just l.a could just be gay
or l.a
you don't know they're all you know
everybody's taking avocados
gay or l.a is [ __ ] hilarious that's a
game that i'm going to play
with hilarious in new york you play like
hamster homeless yes you're homeless you
know you play in brooklyn a lot
yeah yeah i don't care if somebody seems
a little
i don't care anymore i used to want to
be like oh my god i just want to wear
masculine guy and now i'm like i don't i
dated one guy that was a really serious
relationship that he
you guys kind of reminded me to like
same kind of build he would like talk
more with his hands and like
very masculine dude but like people
would joke about
him like being gay right and i was like
i didn't like it at first then i was
like
no i don't know i don't care at all and
like he's super hot to me yeah
yeah women's yeah you think women's
tastes are changing because i think
yeah i think so yes i think men have
been allowed to be a little more
emotional than they have been before
and a little more feminine they have
been before i don't know that people are
brought up today as much
like be a [ __ ] man don't have
feelings get hit in the face you know i
just don't think that people are raised
like that as much anymore yeah
but let me ask you this do you think
though as women not all the time but
like if the guy is handsome like do you
mind being objectified by him i like it
you like it
in bed yeah in bed not in public i know
that if
if i know that somebody actually
respects me cares about me whatever you
can say that
wow whatever come on your
yeah she's like yeah yeah you're not
bringing it at all
it's the bunny hill no you're just
starting i got it i don't i don't know
we'll work up to calling me a family
[ __ ] okay
right there so different in this way
like you don't like it i don't i haven't
experienced it
but i just really like like oh you're so
hot and you're so pretty and you're so
crazy like
like that's my journey so dirty yeah
you're such a daughter
i like that i've never talked dirty to
me i don't know so
i'm not quite sure i like your earrings
your hair looks great today your hair
looks great today
while she's
yeah i want to give you chlamydia like a
koala bear you look like your gpi was
your gpa was really high in school you
did
you like it from anybody i do like it i
think i need to really trust a guy
hit for him to be like no not like first
couple times like when i like somebody
like when i've like been out
that guy that hooked up that 24 year old
in london and first right out of the
gate he was like yeah i didn't like that
though it sounded really disingenuous i
didn't believe that he believed i was a
dirty little [ __ ]
okay he was such a smoke show i was on
this trip i was in london it was a press
trip i was doing for because i have a
big social media account
i hated the girls i was with i hated the
weather i hated everything and i was
like i guess i just have to [ __ ] this
guy
because like there's nothing else to do
on this trip boredom but yeah i didn't
believe
it when he said it so it sounded just
uncomfortable right do you guys say
stuff like that
what like would you do dirty talk um
you know what i do if like a girl's into
it we could
spit in each other's mouths that's like
i'll do that okay
yeah that went from zero to 100 real
quick yeah yeah
spit in each other's mouth yeah yeah i
would do that but it's dirty talk
i mean your car's got good acceleration
yeah yeah that thing [ __ ] horsepower
i think you can do anything with the
right person if they just lead you into
it in the right way yeah
spit in her mouth i didn't know that but
i feel like with dirty talk with me
because sometimes my dyslexia pops up
sexually like i would say the wrong
thing i'd be like you know you
i'd be like you want you know you you
want to suck my dick i mean
you know [ __ ] can i come i want to suck
your dick yeah say something like that
i want to suck your neck yeah sometimes
with texting with sexting i [ __ ] up all
the time i'm like
you know like you want to suck on these
titties i mean i want to suck on your
titties yeah
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild